du poisson de pêche aucune ride pour le
marché de la et bergeries de villepreux
poissonnier fromager bouchée de nombreux
commerçants présents depuis plusieurs
années comme daniel duterte sur le
marché depuis 1972 à la retraite elle
transmet le témoin à son fils stéphane
marché voilà c'est convivial les gens ce
qu'ils ont besoin
on est enfin lancée absolument surtout
surtout très très conviviale et des très
très bon produit et ce qui est très très
agréable aussi ses concerts les enfants
de nos clients dont elle a les enfants
d'aller petits enfants auxquels vous
fuit hôtel de marché fidèle cliente du
marché mireille vient tous les samedis
elle achète sa viande et ses légumes
moi je viens au marché pour sa
essentiellement pour trouver des
produits locaux des produits de qualité
il ya un climat de confiance qui
s'instaure entre
le commerçant et le client c'est ça n'a
rien d'anodine jonas cochet est chargé
de gérer le marché des emplacements des
commerçants au règlement des litiges
il note une fréquentation toujours élevé
du marché de wimereux
maintenant on vient pour le produit pour
la qualité et aussi pour le relationnel
avec les avec les commerçants et les
autres clients tout simplement quand ils
attendent chez des commerçants justement
ça permet aussi de créer un lien un lien
donc affectif et permet aussi par
rapport aux personnes âgées aussi de
garder le contact
c'est très important sauce d'après une
étude de l'insee sur la dernière
décennie de moins en moins de français
font leurs courses sur les marchés ils
étaient près de 6% en 2011